[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 25th of
May I'm Kate Andrews the spectator's
economics editor and your host this week
coming up on the show
will Ukraine's counter offensive
pushback Russia what is in president
zielinski's plan and has the attack
already begun Mark galeotti and Mike
Martin will join me
yesterday Ron DeSantis announced that he
would be running for president what
would American support for Ukraine look
like under a republican
commander-in-chief I'll speak to Freddie
gray and John muirsheimer
in Westminster swella Braverman is in
trouble for a speeding ticket and Boris
Johnson is back in the news over
partygate doesn't matter Katie balls
will join me
new figures this week show that the
inflation rate in the year leading up to
April fell but core inflation Rose what
does that mean and when will the price
pinch stop I'll ask Michael Simmons
and finally the spectator's low-life
columnist Jeremy Clark has sadly passed
away Rod little will join me to discuss
their friendship
before we get going thanks to our
brilliant sponsors can Accord genuity
wealth management for sponsoring the
show can Accord our experienced wealth
planners and investment managers who
offer unwavering support in challenging
times visit can do wealth.com for more
information
and if you enjoy spectator TV then do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon to
make sure that you never miss an episode
the best things in life are free but
only for a month if you subscribe to The
Spectator today you'll not only get your
first month free but after your trial
your pages one pound a week for full
access to our website and app or two
pound a week if you want the print
magazine 2 to claim this offer go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash best
up Mark galeotti a security expert and
director of mayak intelligence writes
about Ukraine's next move for this
week's cover piece after so much talk
over counter-offensives lenski Mark says
cannot afford to play it safe to discuss
Mark joins me now alongside Mike Martin
author of how to fight a war
thank you for joining us Mark and Mike
Mark for The Spectator magazine this
week you write about an upsurge in what
the ukrainians describe as shaping
operations preparing the ground for
battle with attacks on Russian Fuel and
weapons Depots and command centers tell
us more about the situation
well we're in this situation in which
look we know that the ukrainians will
they must launch a counter-offensive and
they've said so them themselves of
course the thing is that there's often
this misconception that a
counter-offensive means some massive
Hammer blow attack whereas actually it
can be a whole series of pulsing
operations that build up and in this
case what we're seeing is certainly the
ukrainians are at present involved in as
you said a variety of operations to do
several things one is put stress on the
Russian supply lines that's always one
of the key points of potential failure
in very voracious Modern Warfare two is
to keep the Russians guessing hopefully
getting them to move forces around to
reinforce areas that actually don't need
to be reinforced
and thirdly just generally to put
psychological pressure on on the Kremlin
Putin does not tend to make good
decisions when he's under stress he
tends to dither or overcompensate and I
think the ukrainians are aware of that
and therefore are hoping that given the
degree to which he's macro managing the
war effort to make him commit some
blunders
Ukraine has just invaded the belgarad
region in Russia what's behind this
well of course the ukrainians say that
it's nothing to do with them it just
happened to be good solid Russian
Patriots who are there to establish a
security Zone around the border now of
course that is a convenient fiction
these uh Russian units which are
fighting on behalf of the key of regime
they operate
entirely within the structures of the
Ukrainian armed forces and they're
essentially controlled by Ukrainian
Military Intelligence I think the idea
is look to do several things first of
all just simply to embarrass the Kremlin
and if you look at for example the sort
of Turbo Patriot nationalist Twitter
social media feeds in Russia I mean
there are a lot of people saying what
the hell is going on why couldn't can
these people just simply stroll across
the border shoot up some border posts
and police stations and then stroll out
yeah so it is generating real trouble
inside Russia's political Elite but
beyond that it's precisely an attempt to
precept to essentially Force the
Russians to have to transfer troops they
have a long border with Ukraine a border
that frankly at the moment is very hard
to defend but nonetheless it may be that
for political reasons they're going to
have to to do something to show that
they're taking this seriously move some
units to these border areas units that
otherwise would be sitting in trenches
ready to repel any UK training attack
Mike what's your take how worried should
the Russians be are the ukrainians
setting a trap to learn them in
uh you know I'd agree with with
everything that Mark said I think the
psychology is is absolutely Central to
this and you know in addition to Putin's
command style and micromanaging you've
got to add to that a Russian military
structure that is really hierarchical
really slow at making decisions you know
everything has to be referred all the
way up and all the way back down again
and and just to look at this this raid
really which is what it wasn't about
around it wasn't an invasion in the
sense of holding territory they were
just going across the border to have a
sort of a smash and grab and to put that
in numbers you know it's really really
good
um operational Arts because what it's
done is the the border the front line
between Russian and Ukrainian troops was
about 1200 kilometers within Ukraine
right stretching from the far north east
down to the Southwest in the curse on
with that Arc that we're also familiar
with from the TV news
but if suddenly the Russian Ukrainian
border comes into play that's all that
bit you know to the Northeast from
Hakeem stretching right around to the
border with Belarus that's that's about
another 1200 kilometers so what the
ukrainians have done is they've doubled
the length of the potential front line
and that does what all strategy seeks to
do which is which is to create dilemmas
for your opponent and the Dilemma here
is you know as Mark said where do we put
our troops and of course if you disperse
troops that opens up opportunities for
your enemies so if the Russians have to
disperse their troops across the front
line that's twice as long the ukrainians
have lots of options and they've taken
advantage of this before
if the if you if your viewers remember
the uh
really really fast Ukrainian Advance
into Hakeem in September 2022 that was
as a result of the Russians thinning out
troops from that region and take them
down into the South to defend Hassan
which the ukrainians were pushing on and
it really just reinforces this the
problem that the Russians have had right
from the start which is that they've
bitten off much more than they can chew
and they don't have enough troops to
achieve the goals the Strategic and
political goals that they've set
themselves and so the ukrainians are
just taking advantage of that Mark
Russian says that they've taken control
of buckmint is this a tactical loss for
Ukraine or not
I think it's more than anything else a
a political loss of sorts but really
this has been one of the most pirate
victories of of this war you know the
Russians essentially decided that
backward mattered and it mattered for
political reasons not least because
Evgeni bregozin The Man Behind the
Wagner mercenary organization
desperately wanted to give the boss a
trophy and in fact part of the reason
why he's become so outspoken in his
criticism to the ministry of defense and
claiming that they're strangling his
troops of ammunition and letting them
down and running away and everything
else is in some ways he's trying to pass
the buck because he clearly had over
promised he had promised Putin a victory
before Victory Day the 9th of May and he
wasn't able to to basically deliver and
so to this end because it was important
to the boss the Russians have had to
throw more and more troops in and some
of these were very very poor quality you
know mercenaries who were recruited from
the Russian labor camp system if nothing
else this war has done wonders for
Russian prison overground adding
um but you know there was either also
these were good troops in in some cases
I mean they have actually had to sort of
throw in for example paratroopers as
well as Wagner's own more experienced
officers so all of this for a city which
sure people can draw lines on a map and
say aha it unlocks an offensive to in
this direction on that but it's clear
that the Russians do not at the moment
and won't for some time have any
significant defensive capability they're
not going to be able to launch another
big offensive quite the opposite they're
now essentially hunkered down in in
defensive mode so from the ukrainian's
point of view this was an opportunity to
bleed the Russians to force them to
concentrate you know what
capabilities they had on a city that
didn't really matter in the grand scheme
of things admittedly the ukrainians have
also taken losses I mean there was a
degree to which this simply became a
grudge match between Kiev and Moscow and
arguably the ukrainians hung on longer
than they really should but either way
they they have basically
held up all of Russia's potential
offensive capabilities all the way
through the spring
fighting for a city that frankly does
not really matter Putin will claim it as
a victory fine well you know may he
enjoy his Laurel wreath but no one I
think is seriously regarding this as an
advance mate do you agree with that yeah
I do I mean is it the 56th biggest
settlement in Ukraine or something I
think if you zoom out uh this pattern uh
fits very much into the uh this the the
backwood fits into the pattern of the
war and largely that is that Russia
decides that it wants to take a
particular place Ukraine realizes that
and then uses that battle to bleed them
whilst this is building up resources for
a strike somewhere else so we saw it in
mariupo right which was eventually the
Russians were going to take that City
they raised it to the ground we had all
the steel works you know right at the
beginning of the war but the ukrainians
knew that if they got the Russians to
focus on that that would enable them to
buy time and space elsewhere
um it happened in several Donetsk over
last summer where it was clear that they
were probably gonna have to pull out but
they did it as slowly as possible to
bleed the Russians as much as possible
while saber repair their offensive to go
south into her son and and now is the
latest version of this the Russians
settle on somewhere and the ukrainians
allowed them to do that and then really
really really drain them of you know
material and men and all the rest of it
whilst they are preparing something else
which we're now seeing the startup they
are now momentum is very clearly passed
the ukrainians now and they're stepping
off
um Mike and Mark's piece he also says
that U.S officials want what they call a
return on investment to its Western
backers the goal would therefore be to
achieve some concrete and politically
powerful objective measured in terms of
territorial gains what will they want
um I I think there has been a
realization that
um the war either needs to be settled in
2023 or needs to be moved into a a
different Tipping Point and the reason
for that is because of the U.S
presidential election next year and as
we can see from some of the characters
that are lining themselves up to be in
that fight it's not clear that U.S
support for Ukraine would continue at
the same level if you know if it becomes
a political football in the presidential
race and so uh that you know everyone's
realized that which is why we saw this
massive inflow of equipment
um you know the beginning of the year
all the tanks coming in January in terms
of return on investment
um I suspect sadly that Mark is right
that there are many politicians who do
view War as a bit of a spreadsheet
um where you know you put these inputs
in and you get the following out
um I think war is much more of a
conversation uh and it's much more
psychological I think that at a minimum
there must be some sort of
spectacular so you know Crimea being put
under siege which Mark mentioned in his
piece or cutting through the Russian
lines and splitting their forces into
two by driving south from zapparesia to
reach the Sea of azov or something like
that
um such that it it changes the
decision-making calculus in Moscow
because effectively what at the moment
both sides are mutually incompatible uh
claims so there's no there's no grounds
for any kind of peace talks at the
moment but a shifting of the dial a
significant changing of the landscape in
Ukraine might open up uh
a landing zone for a negotiated
settlement it's not clear that whether
that will be possible with Putin and so
that's the you know the big question is
does failure on the battlefield in
Ukraine can Putin outlive that and and
and if not then who comes next that
those to me seems the sort of unknowns
at the moment
Mark is there likely to be more
offensives and counter-offensives after
this one
well sadly I don't think this war is
going to end this year so absolutely
this question of whether it's this
year's or next year's run of campaign
Seasons the thing is that again
I mean I I like Mike's uh
characterization of War as a
conversation I mean again it's
essentially how long can the ukrainians
monologue before the Russians get a word
in edgewise and in that context and you
know so much depends on this this
imponderable of precisely what form the
offensive takes and the ukrainians have
been understandably extremely cagey
about what and when frankly to a large
extent even behind closed doors with
their allies
and and so we will have to see the
Russians though I mean their forces are
still powerful but brittle I would
suggest and again it's it's the capacity
to actually convert if you manage to to
stop the Ukrainian offensive and hold
them can you then convert that into a
rollback and I think that's going to be
a lot harder
um for them to do I think really before
the Russians are going to be able to
launch another offensive they're gonna
have to find more troops and that means
either Putin biting the bullet and
deploying conscripts which would be
politically massively unpopular at home
but it means it would allow him to tap
up to 180 000 troops who in some cases
they're actually better equipped and
trained than the mobilized Reserve is
currently in theater or he'd have to
launch another mobilization wave again
massively unpopular last time he did it
more Russians fled the country than
actually got signed up in into the
military so you know these are really
difficult things so I think basically
from the Russians point of view they
will just simply try and hunker down
they feel time is on their side that the
longer they can make this war last the
more chance there is of the Western
Alliance beginning to fragment Western
will to pour billions of pounds dollars
and euros into Ukraine every month will
begin to reduce so I mean in that
context I think they will regard not
losing as in some ways a win
Mark and Mike thanks very much for
joining me
Ron DeSantis yesterday announced his
candidacy to be the Republican nominee
for president of the United States so
far he's the most serious Challenger to
Donald Trump in the upcoming primaries
how would a Republican president change
America's support in Ukraine Freddie
gray writes about it in this week's
magazine and he joins me now alongside
John meersheimer from the University of
Chicago
John and Freddie thanks for joining me
Freddie you write for the magazine this
week about how having a Republican
president could change America's
position on Ukraine under Joe Biden the
U.S has spent more than 70 billion
dollars helping Ukraine how would a
Republican president and I think more
specifically in this piece a trump
president change that
well I think Trump's made it very clear
uh what he intends to do he said that um
he says three things about it he says
first of all uh if he were President
Putin never would have invaded Ukraine
uh it's impossible to say whether that's
true or not
um secondly he says Europe's not paying
enough America's paying far more than
Europe to the war effort and he'd make
the Europeans pay more
and thirdly he says he would resolve the
conflict within 24 hours within a day of
entering the White House and I think
what's quite interesting about this is a
lot of hawks on the British side on the
NATO side and in America on the
Republican hawkish side the Republican
party uh worried that he actually might
do that uh but to their mind that would
mean making concessions to Russia uh
rewarding Putin's aggression as they put
it which would then encourage Putin to
uh be even more aggressive in the future
possibly with other states the baltics
and so on uh and I thought it was
interesting very telling this week that
Boris Johnson who's now become a sort of
global cheerleader for the for the war
effort went to Texas to talk to some
rich uh Texas Republicans and some
politicians and to sort of G them up to
say that you are still backing the right
horse Ukraine's going to win this fight
there's going to be a magnificent
counter punch this summer and the
Russian military will collapse I suspect
a lot of people at lunch believed him he
makes the case very forcefully the
difficulty for the Republican party is a
lot of their voters and the polls show
this a lot of their voters are not
aligned with that position on Ukraine
and as this election approaches that's
going to come into sharper Focus Fred
you mentioned there that Trump says
things like if I have been president
Russia would have never invaded on
comments like that comments that he can
end this war in 24 hours do you think
the public buy it well I think that
points towards a golden rule of
Republican campaign Dynamics now which
is that Trump can say anything and get
away with it and other candidates can't
for instance Ron DeSantis uh recently a
few weeks ago uh found himself sort of
boxed in on the question of Russia
because I think by Instinct he's more of
a conventional more of an atlanticist
but he was pressed by the now sacked Fox
News host Tucker Carlson to say what is
America's national interest in fighting
Russia and Ukraine or being involved in
the war in Ukraine and he replied he
said it's not a vital National Security
interest for America to be further
entangled in Ukraine and he was much
criticized for that in the media and it
didn't result in the Republican base uh
rallying towards him in fact if anything
I'm sure there are lots of other factors
involved if anything his polling has
declined since he made that statement
but Trump can say I'll resolve it in 24
hours and he gets away with it because
nobody sort of asks him the further
questions it needs to be even on CNN a
hostile interviewer only wanted to ask
him do you want Ukraine to win and he
said I just want people to stop dying
and the crowd in New Hampshire broke
into Innovation uh the most sensible
question I think to ask him would be how
exactly are you going to do that right
indeed um we'll come back to Florida's
governor he's had a big week but John I
want to bring you in you're of course
known for saying that NATO should take
some of the blame for what's happening
happening in Ukraine but let's pivot
specifically to their Republican party
position here what is the mainstream
Republican opinion about Ukraine and how
big is this issue going to be the issue
of the war in the 2024 election
I think you have to distinguish between
the elites and the public and it's very
important to understand that what the
public thinks here in the United States
just doesn't matter very much the elites
just do what they please
there's no question that there are a lot
of doubters
in the public both on the Republican
side and on the Democratic side and it's
likely that the number of doubters will
grow with time but the question is how's
that going to affect the elite and the
argument that's being made is that the
Republicans are beginning to go soft on
Ukraine at the elite level and that if
Donald Trump gets elected there's a
really good chance uh that he'll pull
the plug on the ukrainians
this is not going to happen in my
opinion
the United States uh is backing Ukraine
to the hilt and if the United States
withdraws its support for Ukraine its
material support Ukraine is going to
collapse it can't stand up to the
Russians the Russians would win a big
victory
it's hard for me to imagine that any
American leader whether it's Donald
Trump or Joe Biden is going to allow
that to happen it's just not going to
happen we are too deeply committed to
this War uh there's too much
russophobia in the United States there's
too much talk about the fact that this
is an existential threat that we're
facing with Russia for us to cut and run
and allow Ukraine to go under
furthermore just think about what the
consequences will be for China our
credibility people will argue will be
destroyed if we allow Ukraine to lose so
I think Trump
talks a good game
but what he actually does when he's on
in office assuming he gets reelected in
2024 is another matter and I would note
here if there's a final point that
Donald Trump when he ran for president
and in his initial few months in the
White House said that he wanted to
improve relations with Russia he viewed
Putin as a friend he wanted to put an
end to Nato and get out of Europe none
of that happened and in fact what did
happen is that in 2017
it was Trump who started arming the
ukrainians Obama much to his credit had
the good sense not to harm the
ukrainians but Trump decided to arm the
ukrainians and we were as tough on the
Russians during the Trump Administration
as we were in any other Administration
so Donald Trump can talk all he wants
about how he's going to do 180 degree
turn regarding American policy on
Ukraine but in my opinion that's not
going to happen if he gets reelected
you mentioned there that you think more
fatigue will set in when it comes to the
war in terms of American opinions of it
South Carolina Senator Tim Scott has
just launched his presidential campaign
uh with a very different view he thinks
that Joe Biden has not done a great job
of explaining to the American people why
the interventions have been so
substantial in Ukraine but that there is
a case to be made if you look at polling
numbers in the states right now they're
certainly increasing debate between
Americans about just how long the U.S
should be supporting Ukraine a debate
between say one to two years and then
indefinitely but there does still seem
to be a lot of support a majority of
support for helping Ukraine
there's no question about that uh and uh
it's hardly surprising if you look at
how we talk about Russia in the United
States and in the west more generally
these days
um Vladimir Putin is portrayed as the
devil incarnate there's extreme
russophobia in the land and the Biden
Administration and the establishment
foreign policy establishments in the
west more generally have done a
brilliant job of propagandizing uh this
war so it's unsurprising that uh Wars
chunks of the body politic and all these
Western countries are committed to
seeing Russia defeated
do you think it's
pranda that's convinced
in Port Ukraine or is it the fact that
they watch Vladimir Putin March his
tanks over the border into Ukraine
no it's clearly the propaganda campaign
it's truly amazing the extent to which
our discourse here in the west is
limited uh so that we end up supporting
the ukrainians at every turn and
opposing the Russians at every turn
there's hardly anything that's ever said
that's positive about the Russian effort
or that's a possible explanation in
Russia's favor for why this war happened
this is a truly outstanding case of
extreme propaganda the only case that I
think comes close is what happened in
both Britain and in the United States
during World War One you want to
remember that in World War One there was
no equivalent of Pearl Harbor where 9 11
that brought us into the war and as a
result Woodrow Wilson had to go to Great
Lengths to mobilize the American public
to back the war and this was especially
true because the two biggest ethnic
groups in the United States at that
point in time were German Americans and
uh Irish Americans and Wilson was deeply
fearful that the German Americans would
not fight against Germany and the Irish
Americans would not fight with Britain
so we launched an amazing propaganda
campaign
and uh I think that since then there has
been no equivalent to that propaganda
campaign until recently when Russia
invaded Ukraine and we have gone to
Great Lengths to portray uh the Russians
in the most negative light and to
silence people who might have a somewhat
different View and that would include
someone like me of course
Freddy Trump used to get a lot of
criticism when he would go and shake
hands with these dictators and human
rights abusers and his argument would be
well look at the results don't look at
the handshake look at the results I am
moving America away from this heavy
interventionist foreign policy and he
would claim he was successful indeed I
think and he certainly moved the
Democrat Party into a more isolationist
point of view
um do you think one of the reasons he's
so hesitant to say how he would actually
do what he's pledging to do to bring the
war to an end in 24 hours is because
those handshakes would not be feasible
now he would not be able to Buddy up to
Vladimir Putin in the same way he would
have to take more hostile approach and
frankly that that could lead to results
that
um that lead to very different results
than what the president is promising I'm
not sure I think Trump's approach is
always the sort of real estate uh
approach to to foreign policy which is
you know you make deals you take
positions you you deceive people with
your positions if you have to
um and I think where Trump is effective
as a campaigner is that he often says
things that Americans think but no one
in the public eye or no one in the
elites if you like uh will say so he
there's a famous moment when he was
asked about
um foreign authoritarian governments
doing terrible things and he said do you
think we're so innocent uh and this was
taken as a very anti-American statement
but actually I think a lot of Americans
know that their government has not done
uh has done terrible things in the world
and and they're quite honest about that
um so I think he has a he has a
rhetorical ability with it his
deal-making ability as an as in
Statesman is I think as John suggests uh
much exaggerated but you you know the
fact that he would be willing to talk to
Vladimir Putin is willing to say that he
would be willing to talk to Vladimir
Putin is does make him a different type
of politician to a lot of the other
candidates
Freddie this week Florida's governor Ron
DeSantis has launched his presidential
campaign on Twitter and if anyone's
going to be a challenger to trump it is
thought at the moment anyway that Ron
DeSantis will be that person and even if
we just break this down into name
recognition some of the other candidates
running Don't Come Close
with his policy towards Ukraine be much
different from Donald Trump's well his
recent statements on it suggests that no
it wouldn't
um but he'd certainly talk about it more
in the language of international
statesmanship he wouldn't be saying I'll
just make a deal with uh Putin and you
know because I know his strengths and
weaknesses and I know zelenski's
strengths and weaknesses and so I'll
just I'll fix it
um he'll talk more about International
interests and the national interest
and I think so far it looks as though he
knows that the conservative base that he
wants to Rally are much more skeptical
about what America's doing in Ukraine
than the rest of the population and so I
think for now he's he's tilting towards
Trump Tim Scott on the other hand is
tilting towards the more hawkish
position and talking about you know it
being a national interest to degrade uh
Russia's military so that it can avoid
an attack on UK's Sovereign land uh I
think that's a that's a an odd position
and I think a lot of Americans will
think it's an opposition because they'll
think well how is it is Russia really
threatening American sovereignty and is
not the war that is currently being
conducted increasing the likelihood of
the only feasible albeit Unthinkable
attack on uh America from Russia which
is a nuclear one which of course would
be the end of the world
could I quickly just respond to
something that Freddy said
I think he's exactly right that Trump
views himself as a deal maker and he
thinks that he can move in here and he
can talk to Putin he can talk to
zelinsky he can use pressure on zelenski
and he can cut a deal the problem that
Trump faces is not simply that there
would be resistance from the rest of the
establishment if he tried to do that the
problem the real problem is there's no
deal to be had here right
nobody can figure out what the solution
is to shutting this conflict down and
there are two reasons for that one is
the territorial issue the Russians are
not going to give back the territory
they've conquered and the ukrainians
want that territory back and you can't
square that Circle furthermore the
Russians want Ukraine to be a neutral
State and Ukraine wants a security
guarantee and that can only come from
the west and you can't square that
Circle so there is no deal to be had so
you know there's all this talk these
days about using the Chinese as a as a
forced or as a moderator to work out
some sort of deal
that's not a viable argument because
again it has nothing to do with the
Chinese it's the fact that there's no
deal to be had so Trump can talk to
these blue in the face about cutting a
deal but there's no deal to be had
but he would and John obviously you're
the great expert on international
relations so I defer to you on this but
he would have leverage I mean Americans
power is unrivaled he would have
significant leverage over Ukraine
because of the support that America has
provided uh Ukraine and he would have
significant leverage over Russia because
of the threat that America Campos to
Russia and the fact that the war has not
been going according to Russia's plan so
far
I think you're absolutely right that he
would have significant leverage over the
ukrainians not total leverage but
significant leverage but I don't believe
he'd have any leverage over the Russians
the Russians don't trust the Americans
whether it's Trump or Biden as far as
they can throw them and the Russians
have a deep-seated interest in taking as
much of Ukraine as they can uh and
turning the remaining part of Ukraine
into a dysfunctional rump State and
Promises from Donald Trump that they'll
work out some sort of meaningful deal
and therefore the Russians can make
concessions it's not going to wash the
Russians no longer trust us and they
shouldn't trust us
there's also a question about what would
happen to president zielinski if he did
come to the table and walked away with a
deal that your average Ukrainian did not
think was acceptable they could well
oust him and bring in somebody else it
strikes me that there's no guarantee
that either side frankly would
necessarily declare this war over even
if president Trump did I I agree with
that and I think it's not your average
Ukrainian it's the ultra right in
Ukraine there has long been a powerful
ultra-right a nationalist right in
Ukraine uh that wants to make no
concessions to the Russians and is
heavily into de-rucification of uh
Ukraine and those people uh would be
very hard to get on board and
zielinski's had his problems since he
was elected dealing with those people so
I agree completely completely with what
you say your average Ukrainian of course
has has also been out there fighting I
mean clearly there is still support
amongst the country for for trying to
defend what what they want to keep and
but Freddie my last question to you is
if Trump were to become president and he
were to implement his agenda I think
we've established a lot of question
marks over that agenda
um what would other Western countries be
able to do would they be able to keep
supporting Ukraine would they be able to
do this without the United States
I mean I think a trump second Trump
presidency would be a greater threat to
Nato uh than the first presidency was
there was a lot of fear about
um NATO uh being Trump was going to tear
NATO apart and so on because he didn't
really see the point of it uh in his
first term he just was agitating for for
other states to contribute more money he
didn't want America to pay so much I
think in the second term
with this situation in Ukraine with all
the pressures going on I think it would
be a Graver threat to Nato uh I don't
make any moral judgments whether that's
a good or bad thing uh I just think that
would be the dynamic Freddie and John
thanks for joining me on spectator TV
in Westminster this week Home Secretary
swella Braverman has been in trouble
over a speeding ticket and allegations
that she broke the ministerial code and
Boris Johnson has been referred to the
police over allegations that he broke
lockdown rules with Gatherings at
Checkers to tell us about it and to
discuss her politics column this week
Katie balls joins me now
Katie probably the biggest political
story this week is that the net
migration figures have surged and in
your calling for the magazine you write
about how this is politically tricky for
Rishi sunak talk us through it yes
there's lots of weapons to Intrigue this
week which I'm sure we'll go into but I
think by far the biggest story in terms
of what the tourist attraction in
government and in terms of the next
election relates to immigration now as
you say new figures out which show that
the number in terms of legal migration
has pollutant now we knew this was
coming uh partly because the Home
Secretary gave a speech last week and
which was really in anticipation of this
talking about the need to control
immigration the need to retrain workers
in the UK so you no longer have to rely
so much on cheap labor from abroad and
it was a speech which was technically
sanctioned by number 10 but I don't
think was something that they were
designed of their own accord
um and then this week I think to try and
get the front foot
um over these figures announce new
measures in terms of cracking down on
visas for dependents for certain types
of students and this could have quite a
significant uh impact and over a hundred
thousand last year and came in through
this route and but the timing I think it
means that is the question about how
quickly it really kicks in
um due to the Academic Year so you might
not really see anything until next year
in terms of the impact it could have
now are we expecting Rich student to go
much further it's interesting that even
labor is saying net migration is too
high and you have kirst armor going on
at Prime Minister's questions it used to
be a tricky spot for labor they clean I
feel confident enough they can go after
the conservative party's record and yeah
it doesn't feel for now that the Tories
will announce much more in terms of
Crackdown so out of Bravo in the Home
Secretary has raised other ideas behind
the scenes such as raising the minimum
threshold in terms of salaries
um but ultimately I don't think we've
actually seen it wants to go there much
further in this because you have Jeremy
Hunt in the treasury
a big concerns about economic growth and
I think that the trade-off between
um taking these measures which could
hurt the economy in the short term at
least and that calculation is a tricky
trade-off and that's why Rishi sunak
wants to talk about illegal migration
not legal migration and it means that
issue is even more important I thought
that was interesting in your column
because you talk about how CNAC is very
comfortable to say stop the boat he made
it one of his five pledges at the start
of the year but when we talk about legal
migration that's the area that he's much
more nervous to touch and you say would
rather avoid because he doesn't want to
put a figure on it like tens of
thousands likes will Braverman is trying
to do there have been reports that he's
been pushing back on braver men when she
wants to increase the criteria and make
it harder for people to come here do you
think that sunac will be able to fudge
this for a while longer and do you think
he might have to make this a priority
when we get perhaps a new set of pledges
next year assuming that he meets the
current ones there are some question
marks around those pledges so I think
that it's interesting that he won't put
a specific figure on what he thinks net
migration should be at if you read into
what he has said when he's impressed and
interviews where he's quite
uncomfortable it seems to be that he
says he wants to go back to what he
inherited when he became prime minister
which is around 500 000. now I think
that figure sounds very big which is
probably one of the reasons he does want
to say out loud
I think it should be at half a million
because I don't think you think you can
have that conversation
um really until you have a grip on a
legal migration perhaps at that point
you can start to have a conversation
about what the economy needs what the
plan is to reduce it and but that's part
of the reluctance at the moment and then
I think there is a chance
um going into the next election that the
tourists are trying to move on this
labor are currently backing policies
that would restrict legal migration so
the Tories are not backing so this will
be a dividing line that the Tories want
to have over labor not something labor
can take points from them on but I think
you get back to Illegal migration and
this is everywhere
even if Richard didn't manage to do a
lot in terms of stopping the boats he
would still I think potentially have
political pain as a result of these
figures and you'll see lots of people go
in the attack there's a very discomfort
in the Tory party and it's pledge which
is to uh you know stop the boats release
around appointed by election to show
it's going the right direction if that's
not there what does he have to say hmm
let's turn to the Home Secretary
personally there was pressure on Rishi
c-neck this week to launch an
investigation into a recent speeding
ticket and the way that she handled it
um within the civil service but uh
Richardson has decided not to launch
that investigation it seems that swirl
Braverman is in the clear
yes I think it's developed rather than
it is looking safe from that perspective
and you have a situation by which this
story broken the Sunny Times in the mail
on Sunday
um a story
um ultimately regarding a speeding find
she received when she was attorney
general when she became home secretary
under Liz truss
um she asked civil servants whether it
was possible for the speed awareness
course that she was planning to pick
over the points on the vine to have that
in a one-on-one setting and the civil
servants refused to look into that I
went to political Aid and the question
was did she break the ministerial code
by asking civil servants to ultimately
deal with what was a personal matter now
the defense is that she is a protective
person as Home Secretary you have around
the clock security so this is a question
which
um is reasonable for those reasons now
Richard Scenic has consulted with his
independent ethics advisor and has
effectively said that he's been advised
that it doesn't really matter further
investigation he does not think that
Sarah bravaman broke the ministerial
code and I think
you've seen this week how divisive
several problems as politician because
opposition parties some civil servants
and some in her own party were quick to
go in the attack that in her own party I
think it was more the anonymous approach
um but I think generally this decision
that is being welcomed within the Tory
party because
um yes you had MPS on the right who
pretty much always back Sue out of
Brahman those situations defending her
saying it was a stitch up but you also
MPS in the middle of the party MPS on
the left at the party who uh well they
admit they're not the biggest suada fans
out there but they thought this was
really a technicality and not something
which is a resigning matter and of
course we've just seen the result of the
Dominic Robb inquiry was there any
element here of Rishi sunak sitting back
and thinking gosh if I do launch an
investigation to this if I do open up
this can of worms it brings the
threshold even further down as to what I
might have to investigate and at that
point it almost seems like a
free-for-all yeah I think there is a
factor you have Richard cynics saying in
his first speech I will lead a
government of integrity
um but there comes a point which is well
does that mean every single time the
opposition parties say oh you said
you're doing you'd lead the government
of integrity and this doesn't follow
this point here he then has to spark an
inquiry so I think it was an important
decision in the sense that there is a
creeping concern in the Tory party
um that uh some people call it the blob
but you know civil servants uh they feel
uh would rather have a labor government
and they feel the Dominic Rob ruling
made it probably more likely in our own
environment but other secretary of the
state can find themselves in the firing
line for these reasons
um so choosing not to have an inquiry I
think has calmed some of the concerns
particularly in cabinet actually about
um how it's all going to shake out in
the future
uh that's an important point I think
that um you know when when the
opposition party says well you know
you're not holding yourself to Integrity
they probably feel that way about a lot
of areas of policy a lot of decision
making it would be difficult to act
every single time
um lastly Katie I want to come on to
Boris Johnson who is back again
partygate is back again talk us through
it yeah I think we're in a groundhog day
when it comes to Boris Johnson and
covert and partygate and rules I was
just on a loop yeah uh the show's back
in town yeah now get your tickets now
this is not even to do the Privileges
committee the Privileges committee we
are expecting to have its finding soon
probably the next couple of weeks in
terms of where the Boris Johnson misled
Parliament on partygate but this is a
whole new thing in the sense that um
Boris Johnson is having his legal fees
paid by the taxpayer by the government
taxpayer and
as a result
um the cabinet office the cabinet office
appointed lawyers now he as a head of
the cover inquiry he passed over and
lots of details before preparing the
evidence so Diaries and so forth and
figures in the cabinet office uh saw in
the Diaries visits to Checkers
potentially also the number 10 flat
which they thought looked as though they
were beyond the rules so the number of
people going family members um and
therefore these uh figures say that
under the civil service code they had to
flag that they flagged to officials and
the cabin office referred it to the
police and that that has created a
massive round in many different
directions and you have Boris Johnson uh
or at least friends of Boris Johnson
saying he could sue the government you
have the covert inquiry saying why
haven't we had access to some of these
things that we need for our inquiry
supposedly they have everything yeah
it's clear they don't more threatening
to Sue and then you also have Rishi
suneck and all this because some Anisa
Boris Johnson are saying we think the
prime minister is complicit ministers
had a role in signing this off going to
the police so in the cabinet office
firmly denies but it just shows you I
think the level of Bad Blood spinning in
lots of different directions so I think
in I suppose what does this all mean in
terms of what we're going to be seeing
and what's going to be happening in
politics well it means that even if
Boris Johnson is clear on privileges
committee he potentially has another
party gate issue hanging over him and I
think
it shows how the covert inquiry could be
pretty poisonous and tricky for the Tory
party as a whole when you think in the
run-up to an election and currently an
Evidence side of it and then finally
what does it mean for Rishi sunak
there's been some excited talk
um of how letters could go in I would
take that with a pinch of salt that idea
we are heading to another political
leader being ousted of course lost
things happen in British politics but it
is a small group for now of Boris
Johnson loyalists who are pretty unhappy
and they don't think resident has been
sufficiently loyal to him the vast
majority of MPS on the WhatsApp groups
or in conversations and are saying calm
down everyone let's just you know stay
United what are you actually accusing
people of but I do think Russia has a
bit of a problem at the moment in the
sense that
it might be coverage it might be the MPS
but the past few weeks I felt a little
bit loose in terms of
um some cabinet ministers speaking out
with speeches some Tory MPS kind of
freelancing with their views on policy
and they get a lot of attention because
for 16x government isn't saying as much
and all together I mean you can buy it
on today you know these Anonymous
briefings about has some Boris Johnson
MPS are going to obstruct vicious Unix
Premiership is just creating a very
messy picture of the Tory party which I
think is the last thing Russia student
like needs if he is going to have a
chance of turning things around I am
still fascinated by an infuriated
biparty gate but I think I'm probably
one of three people in the UK that still
feels that way what about the Tory party
I mean when party gate resurfaces when
Boris Johnson resurfaces like this you
know what are the conversations
happening inside the Tory party over it
presumably some people want to come out
and defend the foreign prime minister
other people just want to move on from
this completely of course rashishunak
himself got a fine for code that
breaches of the rules so
um surely for a lot of people it's in
their best interest just to move on I
think the the vast sense in the Tory
party is that they all want to move on a
large part of the reason Boris Johnson
is not prime minister was the sense of
wanting to move on there were MPS who
faculty did like Boris Johnson as a
prime minister
um they supported him but it felt as
though they could never Shake themselves
free of this rolling story and Scandal
so I think what these stories do is yes
there are some people who defense for
Boris Johnson that obviously think
Russia actually take a firmer line on
defending Boris Johnson and also lots of
people saying why are we still talking
about partygate in a week of inflation
and look at those migration figures you
know that there are bigger issues out
there
um but what I think it all does do is
just confirm that sense amongst a
majority of Tory MPS that they don't
want to go back to the Boris Johnson
days Katie thanks for joining me
it's been a big week for economics too
the latest immigration figures came out
today and inflation numbers earlier this
week to give us a briefing I'm joined by
our data editor Michael Simmons
Michael the net migration figures are
out this morning everyone has been
anticipating these figures and they are
higher than they were last year but
significantly lower than what we were
told they were going to be yes so
estimates that came from the CPS Fink
tank and also were breached out by the
home office suggested that at their very
lowest they were going to be 700 000 and
some people said that they could even go
as high as a million but the net figure
released today by the ons was 606 000
which is significantly lower than what
was expected now part of this is to do
with changes in the um ons's methodology
but I think there was definitely still
you know High bowling in these in these
estimates and the figure you know has
surprised everyone and then a lot of the
increase within that figure is actually
accounted for by Ukrainian refugees and
also Hong Kong bno and passport holders
so I think that the today's news really
changes the narrative on migration where
we've been going is a rising and Rising
thing the ons actually say themselves
that in the last few quarters the kind
of growth has slowed so it may be that
the the spikes in migration are a
temporary factor of some of the
humanitarian crises we've been going
through now I don't think it should be
surprising that it is the refugee
figures the humanitarian route that has
led to quite a big jump and we should
say student numbers are also going up
tier two workers are also going up but
it does seem like the refugee figures
have had a really big impact here I
don't think that should be surprising
given the fact that the UK opened its
doors last year and people were very
happy to do so but you're right about
the narrative Michael it over the past
few weeks we haven't even been talking
about the refugees it's been all focused
on the students yep it's been focused on
the students because the students are
the largest the largest group and
student visas certainly have increased
as well as the number of dependents that
are coming on student visas has been
going up over the years and that's
partly why the government announced sort
of actions to kind of try and try and
curb that but but the student numbers as
a proportion of all non-eu immigration
have actually gone down from I think it
was about um 49 to 37 of the total
um net immigration 47 to 39 yeah and so
even then it looks like um that the the
students are coming they're staying for
a short time and there's even evidence
in the data that they're starting to
leave so it seems sort of less of a
problem if you call it a problem of that
part of the the kind of immigrant group
it's also worth saying though obviously
they're still higher than historic
Trends but the data actually also showed
that there they seem to be starting to
kind of leave faster students don't all
come here and then want to stay here
forever you know some of them will do
their course and then go back so we
could see that this number
um kind of being at a peak what
certainly has been true in the narrative
before the release and has been
confirmed by the release though is the
change in where people come from and
into the UK you know historically that's
because of our membership of the
European Union it's predominantly been
people from the EU but now people coming
here from the EU the net there was
actually a net outflow so the net
um immigration figure is entirely now
made up basically of non-eu migrants and
that's what's kind of hit record highs
so now our top Visa groups are Indians
Nigerians Chinese so that's the real
change in the kind of an immigration
narrative yeah it
by when Boris Johnson and pretty Patel
changed the immigration policy back in
2020 they designed the system so it
would be easier for uh migrants coming
from outside of the EU to come here not
there wasn't free movement for anybody
anymore but they did lower the
thresholds for that starting salary they
did extend The Graduate scheme so
students could stay here and look for a
tier two job you know the system has
been changed by Tory is it it puts
politicians today in a slightly
difficult position because of course you
know it is their fellow colleagues who
so recently changed the scenario if you
don't like it you still have to take
some responsibility for it yeah I mean
if brexit we say was about taking back
control the government has taken back
control of its borders of the
immigration system but it has decided to
certain for certain groups at least you
know turn on the Taps and there are good
economic reasons for this you know we
have still have over a million vacancies
in the job market a huge proportion of
the increase in worker visas is for
people working in the NHS and social
care
exactly right
yep so these are jobs that need to be
filled in so the government cannot
really claim that this is something they
don't have control over there there's
just there's a an economic case for
migration that they have chosen to
accept now of course people might say
there are you know cultural reasons why
do you still want to curb this number
but it's a balance between that and the
the economics and clearly the government
is going with the economic argument for
you know letting more and more workers
into the economy while I have you here
Michael we also have some big inflation
data out this week the April Figures
were really a key moment because the
bank of England I mean broadly speaking
the consensus was saying once we get to
Spring that is when the inflation rate
is going to start to fall dramatically
of course we've heard this before and it
hasn't fallen we've been in double
digits but in April we did see that
headline figure fall to a rate of 8.7
percent down from 10.1 percent however
core inflation which excludes the
volatile stuff energy food that's
actually up
yeah so that's um what's really been
surprising about the inflation figure as
you say everyone knew that they would
that we were going to see our first big
fall in the headline figure and that's
because the energy price Rises that
happened this time last year have sort
of fallen out of the comparison period
so prices are are not that high relative
to what they were a year ago but core
inflation as you say which excludes food
alcohol Energy prices tobacco that's
actually gone up to a 30-year High I
don't think it's been as high as this
since um 1992 and that shows really that
inflation at the center of Britain's
economy that's not so much affected by
imports and exports is still going up so
with it being nearly seven percent it
looks harder and harder to see how Rishi
sunak is going to get it down to his
Target of halfing it this year because
it will still go down as Energy prices
fall out but it's it's not going to go
lower than core inflation they can't
well this is what's so worrying is that
it does seem that some of that inflation
around say core goods and around
Services is becoming embedded into the
system
a grim point to end on but an important
one too Michael thanks for joining me
thank you
and finally Jeremy Clark the spectator's
low life columnist for 23 years has
sadly passed away
readers will be well aware of his battle
with cancer
he spent the last years of his life in
Provence France with his wife catriona
his many friends at The Spectator miss
him dearly one of them are columnist Rod
little joins me now
Rod you write a beautiful tribute to
Jeremy Clark in this week's magazine his
writing you say was always the truth why
do you think that was so important
um he was very very different to the
rest of us as journalists there was
there was no artifice
in the way he wrote he didn't exaggerate
for effect he didn't use understatement
for effect
he really called it precisely as he saw
it and
um in a way that in an interesting way
kind of in a rather wide diet way
um it was always everything was a
revelation to him and it didn't matter
if something contradicted with his own
personal political beliefs or his his
own philosophy or or it was something
which might annoy the public if he
mentioned it he didn't it just didn't
intercede with what he actually put down
on paper and I think that's why aside
from obviously the fact that he he did
work hard in this at his at his writing
I think that's why it endured so
brilliantly and people loved it so much
because uh it was unfiltered uh
perfectly unfiltered people sometimes
used to say to me um
Rod little you know you're the second
column I turned to every week in The
Spectator normally when I hear things
like that I want to straddle whoever it
is is the First Column they turned to in
The Spectator it was always Jeremy
always yeah
Rod you and Jeremy started at The
Spectator at roughly the same time you
were friends for many years what was it
like when you first met him and what was
it like joining his columnist together
um it was interesting
theoretically we should have been
friends right from the office but you
know
um uh at our class of society I'm afraid
football tribalism rather he's rather
important and Jessa Jesse was a hammer a
West Ham support and on new wall and
there is no greater enmity on Earth and
between those two but nonetheless that
in a way became a kind of cement for our
for our friendship because we both
supported clubs so the other could
grudgingly acceptable proper working
class football clubs and there we were
thrown into this rather
it's it's a different place to spectator
today as well it's rather more
meritocratic uh when when Chester and I
started working there almost everyone
was a [__] Duchess you know it was
remarkable it was a very very Highborn
atmosphere uh where everyone had been a
private school and and they were all
related to uh William the Conqueror
so it was a totally different world yeah
a totally different world but the
interesting thing in a way is that while
I I was perfectly capable of being very
chippy about this
um and uh cetera was always thought of
me as a Hardline socialist which which
probably gives you an indication as to
where he stood on the political Spectrum
uh but but while I could get quite
chippy about the the the the the the the
Highborn atmosphere of of of The
Spectator it didn't bother him one bit
really he knew he wasn't part of it
which is why I guess in the early years
we cleaved together quite quite a lot uh
but there was no grudge he was I think
in truth sir
a proper working class story
you know of the old school who actually
quite liked your toffs uh quite like the
toss but didn't have much time for the
middle class I think that's probably
where Jeremy would be located
you write in your tribute that you had
some riotously drunken evenings together
can you tell me about any of them
um
probably actually a lot fewer than we
should have had because
after a while both of us lived a very
very long way away from from London
um so our chances to meet up we would
always a various spectator bashes we
would always hang out together you do
write though that he came to your
wedding wrote a lovely piece about it
for the magazine and he was there at
your daughter's christening he sounds
like he was a very committed friend
uh in those early days yes I mean we
didn't so much grow apart it's just
moved apart uh in in the later years but
in those early years yes he was uh we we
always Whenever there was a spectator do
I always gravitated to Germany and vice
versa even when one notable occasion
he was in a spectator passion about 2006
or seven and I saw this very tall black
man
and and spectator dues back in 2006
seven were whiter than the Ku Klux Klan
dinner dance mate I'm telling you and
there's this very very very tall black
man there who I recognized immediately
as being Cass pennant who was the leader
of West Ham's inter-city firm hooligan
team and who was there rubbing shoulders
uh with the Archbishop of Canterbury and
the chancellor of The X Factor uh at
Jess's behest and he was great and
Cassie is actually a very very good
bloke uh and a very entertaining man to
be around
um but but at bashes like that we'd
always hang out together I suppose you
write that you would chew the fat and
spit it out and this is something I
think readers of Jeremy's column will
really want to know did he talk like he
wrote and what did he like to talk about
I think to a great degree in those early
days when I knew my lesson
I don't think he was very happy
um
in the you know he was he was always
desperately worried about his family
always hoping that they they would be
able to to to to get their lives on
track to do the right thing
um and it was only later I think when he
when he found
um the lovely katria catriona that that
that he became kind of anchored and and
they uh
and a much happier and contented human
being which you know ironically
coincided of course with with that
horrible horrible illness uh which he
battled for 10 years
uh and did so again in in that same way
uh without Fury or anger uh with a kind
of uh
buddhist-like acceptance of fate
um and without ranker and even found in
its beauty you know uh whether it be
the conversations with the taxi drivers
or the oncologists or or
just local people you could he could
find beauty in that and that that's
writing of a extraordinarily High degree
you know finally Rod you say that Jeremy
was at points unsettled as you just said
they're sometimes anchored and often
pissed
but how do you think he changed over the
years yeah I think he changed a lot I
think is I mean we didn't see very much
of each other in the last few years I
think
but I I I do know and you can tell from
his writing that he was
you know uh immensely cheered by his
grandkids and he loved being with them
and and uh and of course he adored uh
catriona Ellen had a had a very very
happy life there
um
I think in a way
um the tragedy of course of Germany is
it he's not rich and famous you know he
is he should be he's a very very very
good writer but I don't think he was
ever an editor's writer
um
because he didn't really care what
anyone else thought he just wrote what
he believed in
um and I don't think he was a
he wouldn't be able to say things for
Mass consumption simply to please the
masses it was just an honesty that was
always there and that is what made him
such a superb writer and also probably
what kept Him skinned for most of his
life
uh well our current editor has written
about how Jeremy would file word perfect
one of the only columnists and writers
truly truly untouched
um Rod you say that you will miss him
and you will miss his writing and I
think coming from you that is the
highest compliment thank you very much
for joining me thanks Kate cheers
that's it for this week once again thank
you to canacore community wealth
management for sponsoring the week in 60
minutes can Accord will provide you with
the expertise you need to build your
wealth with confidence visit
kennedywealth.com for more information
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
foreign